it's time for cnn unseen where we unpack
the stories behind the headlines and for
that we turn to fox news contributor
raymond arroyo all right raymond while
the media is focusing they're going
crazy on this january 6 extravaganza and
also of course ukraine
there is a huge story we're missing yes
laura and it's in our backyard and it
has dangerous consequences biden is in
la for the summit of the americas now
having read and talked to a lot of
people about this agenda for the summit
and the invitees i thought to myself
before the president had even taken off
he's already stumbled and then he did
that's the president boarding air force
one this morning the problem is the
stumbles are continuing this summit was
convened to address climate change and
migration the only leaders of the
countries with the most migrants
guatemala honduras and el salvador are
not coming neither is mexico obrador is
boycotting because biden did not invite
those latin leaders that he considers
dictators
we look forward to hosting foreign
secretary edward
ebrod as the mexican representative
representative at the end of the day to
your question we just don't believe
dictators should be invited and that's
and so we don't regret that and we will
stand the president will stand by his
principle
okay so let me get this straight laura
we don't meet with dictators but the
president's about to make a trip to
saudi arabia to meet with the sultan in
a few weeks and he's trying to hatch an
iran nuclear deal
well i'll add to this we won't meet with
dictators we're enriching dictators with
everything we're doing with china and
now venezuela gets to sell oil to the eu
right i mean and then we're we're
re-engaging with iran and then we're
going to get saudi arabia to you know
make more money over there on oil
because we're not going to drill for it
what do you mean they're not oh they
bend over backwards to dictators maybe
except putin that's about it
all right and even richard haas at the
council on foreign relations he tweeted
that the summit of america's looks to be
a debacle the us has no trade proposal
no immigration policy no infrastructure
package instead the focus is on who will
and who will not be there yeah well
i i think you and richard haas are being
a little negative laura i know major
countries are scattering they're not
paying attention to the united states
but vice president kamala harris the u.s
border czar is on the job laura she just
announced 1.9 billion in private
investments in latin america it is about
doing what we know is possible to
maximize the capacity
of the people in that region
doing it in a way that really
understands the power of ecosystems of
considering nations holistically
[Applause]
we together
have generated more than 3.2
billion dollars of investment in the
region
[Applause]
and you applaud because we all know that
is a substantial sum
only what she calls that donation of
investment it does nothing to stem the
caravan headed this way laura nor does
it address the biggest national security
threat we face talk about an unseen
story reuters did a trade analysis of
the last six years or so putting mexico
aside guess who has surpassed the united
states in trade with latin america you
said it earlier china is now the leading
trade partner with latin america
spending 247 billion to the us's
174 billion this week is not helping
well of course it's not going to help
it's not going to do anything to stop
the migration they know it but they're
happy to you know help other countries
get richer as we get poorer so i hope
all these countries do better in our own
hemisphere but not going to do anything
and i'm just still stuck on that
pronunciation of obrador i know you did
the spanish accent raymond obrador right
but the press secretary seemed to have
an interesting evolution in the way
could help
yes well and how is uh how is the
january sixth
stuff affecting this summit if at all
you know there was a mexican ambassador
who was interviewed and he said
this is causing an instability in the
hemisphere because the the latin
american countries look at this and they
say look the united states can't handle
democracy all that well why should we
take leads from them so this
dramatization
has heavy consequences and i think
people don't recognize that you know
while they're making their political
points but kamala harris did do her own
diplomatic outreach to an asian country
last week laura she met with south
korean boy band bts
very nice
[Music]
when we see hate and prejudice it's
meant to make people afraid
and it's meant to make people feel alone
and therefore without power wow
i have to tell my mom
laura it's a lot easier to deal with bts
than than deal with that border crisis
and you don't even have to give them
perpetual feeding and housing so it's
pretty good um bts um i was going to use
another acronym to follow that but i
better not no it would be very immature
for me all right raymond thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else